morning so I want to talk about scaling
up and in particular in the context of
how engineering comes to play with that
kind of idea because I think it does
um and so a good place to start with
that is what is it that makes scaling
difficult and there are a variety of
things I think but often one of the
sorts of things that we think about is
stuff like this one of the responses to
needing to scale up is to come up with
ideas like this sort of production line
style thinking and there's a fundamental
difficulty here because this is not our
problem this is never ever our problem
this is not even close to our problem
with software and so any idea that's
about scaling up like that is run
our problem is very different so so we
develop software we we crystallize ideas
into a form that can be executed by a
computer and the result of that
is a stream of bytes
and one of the things that you is unique
about a stream of bytes
is that we can reproduce that
essentially at zero cost for as many
times as we like
so we never have a production problem in
the sense of physical things our problem
is something else
so when we're talking about scaling up
we're not talking about scaling up in
the same way as anything else
we're talking about scaling up something
very different indeed and that ought to
change the way that we think about it
so this is not a production scaling
problem so that means applying
production line style thinking which to
some degree we're all kind of
acclimatized to thinking that way
because we grew up in an industry like
in industrialized societies we're primed
to think that way but but that's the
wrong way of thinking about this
so waterfall for example is a PR is a
software production line what's for
people even sometimes talk about it that
way which means it's not suitable for
software
doesn't work has never worked the only
time I've ever seen it work is when
people cheated the process
so that's not the right answer
or any really reproducible reproducible
standardized approach cookie cutter
style approach to developing software
that's not what software is and it's not
how it works
so software development I would argue is
very strongly in exercising learning
because in whatever context we find
ourselves in we are always
creating something for the first time
because otherwise we'd create it for
free
from what we had before because
production is free for us
so we're always doing something new
it might not be new in the world it
might only be new in our context in our
team but it's always new
and that means it's always about
learning and discovery
there's another aspect to software
development that's certainly an
increasing part of our daily lives which
is that we build systems that are much
more complicated than any human being
can hold in their entirety in their
heads and understand every ramification
of them and so in order to be able to
deal with that we've got to also worry
about managing the complexity of the
systems that we build and there are
tools for us to be able to do that
mental tools that we need to apply
to be able to do those sorts of things
so how do we scale those kinds of things
those kinds of activities how do we
scale learning and how do we scale
managing complexity
it's not an easy question to answer
sorry I'll just move my cursor off the
screen a little bit that's
something I've got 10 things five in
each category that that will help us to
do these things and certainly for for
people here at the at an agile
conference you're going to recognize
many of these things particularly on
this side which is agile is
fundamentally about learning so
iteration feedback incremental
development evolving our system step by
step working experimentally learning and
inspecting and adapting but being
empirical learning from production and
and changing our behaviors from there
those are all at the heart of what real
agility means you can do all of these
things without big ceremonies or
anything this and and if you're doing
these things you're definitely being
agile if you're doing the ceremonies
without those things you're not being
agile these are at the core of what it
is that it takes to be able to to Really
um learn and be be good at it and then
we need to
um optimize to manage complexity we need
ideas like modularity cohesion
separation of concerns reducing coupling
abstraction
so that we're able to make changes in
one part of a system without worrying
about what's going on in another part of
a system that allows us to move more
quickly
now the problem here when we're talking
about scaling is that information is a
kind of slippery idea
the the there's information in our
organization and the way that our teams
interact with one another and the
problems are the same the problems that
I've just described in terms of managing
complexity are really fundamental to
information they're not really about any
particular technology or even
software in general they're true about
us as well a team is in information
system and the ways that team is
interact with one another
have the same kind of problems of
concurrency and coupling and so on and
we need to deal with those if we want to
do things at scale
one of the difficulties is that and this
is always an increasing difficulty as we
start to scale up software Beyond a
certain size is that dependencies really
don't scale very well at all
as as our systems get bigger and bigger
the smallest change can have a
disastrous effect
and so in order to be able to scale
software development we need to find
ways of limiting the impact of these
kinds of changes
so what must we do
we need to think about and recognize
that software is a creative discipline
it's a discipline that's founded around
exploration and learning and we need to
optimize for that
dependencies in code and in
organizations are caustic but they are
also unavoidable if we need two parts of
a system whether it's a human system or
a software system to interact in some
way there's going to be coupling between
them to some degree and so we got to
figure out how we're going to manage
that how we're going to deal with that
and so
in order to grow our ability to create
software we need to apply creative I
would argue engineering style thinking
to managing those sorts of problems
so here are a few principles that that
seem to me to be to be relevant here so
I've already mentioned a couple we need
to optimize for Learning and for
managing complexity and as part of that
in for both of those things it's
absolutely essential that we control the
variables that we're able to try things
out and control the variables
sufficiently so that we know
what are the results of our experiments
are
if I make a change to my software in the
hope that it's going to win more win
more sign ups from users and you make a
change to the software which
accidentally wins more sign ups from
users how do I know the impact of my
change how do I control the variables so
that I can see the impact of my change
and not yours
one way in which I could do that is I've
been working smaller steps release more
frequently and I'm more likely to be
releasing my change separately from
yours then and I'll be able to see the
impact but there are many ways in which
controlling the variables matter if
we're writing a test how do we know that
the results of the tests are repeatable
and reliable by controlling the
variables putting a system into a state
that we want it to be in and so on
we want to get to the point where we can
make more evidence-based decisions that
means that we need to start thinking and
working more experimentally
the previous speaker was talking about
trying ideas and learning from those
ideas and trying and be willing to be
wrong that's fundamental to learning and
that must be part of what it is that we
do
the way that I I phrase it slightly
differently but the idea is the same I
suggest that the the granddaddy of
learning is science and so we can learn
lessons from science and we can apply
those that's why I call this engineering
it's kind of a practical form of
scientific style reasoning but one of
the deep philosophical ideas of science
is that we're going to start out
assuming that our ideas are wrong not
that they're right and then we're going
to try and figure out how we learn where
they're wrong and how they're wrong and
how we can improve them
that's a much better way of learning
than assuming that we're right and
trying to prove that we're right
it turns out
so never assuming that we're starting
off with the right answer he's probably
a good starting place
then we find ways to falsify our ideas
how would we show that we were wrong
that's a better stronger proof than
trying to prove that we're right I can
assert that all swans are white and I
can never prove it but as soon as I see
one Black Swan I know the horse ones
aren't white and that's falsification at
work it's a stronger statement and this
is one of the lessons that we learn from
science
the other aspect of scaling and dealing
with taking this more engineering
approach to thinking about this kind of
thing is to check where we are all the
time in our progress have kind of
essentially real-time monitors of where
we are in in our progress in in our you
know the safety of our changes and so on
so I I've kind of led up to I suppose
asking this question what is it that you
think of when you hear the phrase
continuous delivery
I suppose I'm one of the people that's
responsible for helping to popularize
this as a term and as an idea although
I'm not the originator of the term and
neither is jazz continuous deliveries
was is one of the first principles of
the agile Manifesto as an idea but
optimizing is for continuous delivery is
um really what Jazz and I were talking
about when we wrote about it in our book
of the same name you might be thinking
of stuff like build automation
and you'd be right that's part of it
deployment automation
devops
deployment Pipelines
always deploying to production
maybe sometimes automated testing for
sure
I'd use this as a definition though none
of those things are definitional all of
those things are activities that we
might undertake to achieve continuous
delivery but I'd say that this is part
of the definition working so that our
software is always in a releasable state
and we want to try and keep it in a
releasable state for as much of the time
as we possibly can
that's a big idea and it's a challenging
idea and it goes to the heart of
pointing out where scaling is difficult
I'll try and point out what I mean by
that but let's start with the words
always always in a releasable state
always sounds quite difficult so how do
we do that kind of thing
well we optimize for sorry let me just
step back
optimize for fast feedback
I pressed it again twice the delays are
on that slide optimize the fast feedback
frequent feedback on the release ability
of our systems we want to try and get
our system into a releasable state after
each small change and evaluate that
that's at the heart of continuous
delivery thinking and we want to do that
all of the time as frequently as we can
possibly achieve
release ability it determines the
boundaries of scalability if we can work
so that our system that we are working
on whatever it is is releasable by
definition then
we're in a good State it's tested as
thoroughly as we're going to test it
before we release it because now it's
releasable that would be silly to retest
it more after that so it's ready to go
at that point so this starts to put a
boundary on how scalable we can go
one of the ways in which practically we
can see the impact of that is through
building deployment pipelines a
deployment pipeline is an alternate
automated mechanism
to assert and Define the release ability
of our system
we're going to build
and as as automated as possible
evaluation of our system so that we can
make a change get feedback on our change
and understand how it stands in terms of
its release ability
um I can say this with more
um assertive more Assurance than I can
say most things that I say because I'm
the person that invented the term
deployment pipeline a deployment
pipeline goes from commit to releasable
outcome if you have a deployment
pipeline that goes to something else
it's not a deployment pipeline it's
about getting to release ability it's
about being definitive for release
ability that's kind of at the core of
the idea
this means if we have this feedback that
we can be confident in to make progress
we can gain confidence by testing our
system very thoroughly within the bands
of the deployment Pipeline and testing
thoroughly in this context largely means
automated testing because we can test it
many more times than any army of people
can do
um and I genuinely think that this is
real software engineering this is part
of an engineering discipline and I I
find it hard to imagine how you can
count it as engineering if you're not
doing this kind of level of testing
really this gives us this gives us a
huge in step forward in a confidence of
our systems and our ability to release
them safely
so what does it take to be confident
well here's my deployment pipeline again
and first we want to make sure that our
tests pass locally that's going to be
the fastest feedback that we can get as
part of the development process then we
want to know that the code does what the
developers think it's doing verifying
those this catches about research says
this catches about 58 of production
failures just that style of testing then
we want to test verify that it does what
the users wanted to do we want to
evaluate it in lifelike scenarios in
production like test environments to get
feedback on that and then we'd like may
want to check that it's nice to use with
human beings not regression testing
exploratory testing to try and learn
just how it is that how the system is to
use as it's being developed not
afterwards and then maybe is it fast
enough is it resilient enough is it
scalable enough is it secure whatever it
is that determines in our context
release ability is it regulatory
compliant perhaps
I've built pipelines with all of these
checks in at some point
at that point if all of those things
have been determined by the pipeline we
can be confident in releasing it into
production it's a releasable change
in terms of what do we mean by
um
fast feedback which I said earlier well
for the first part the development Focus
part I recommend that you aim for a
target of feedback in under five minutes
and for the whole thing to determine the
release ability I aim that you I suggest
that you aim for a target of under an
hour that may sound extravagant but
people have done this with highly
complicated systems highly complex
systems
um and very very large systems too
one example is a company that I worked
at we built a financial exchange and
just to put this into context of how
many tests we'd be running hundreds of
tests before a commit about 35
000 commit stage tests under five
minutes about 20 000 acceptance tests
user scenarios and that was exploratory
and then hundreds of performance tests
and we we recorded the worst hour of our
system in production and replayed it at
five times load and these kinds of
things and then thousands of other kinds
of tests so there's a lot of testing
going on as part of this effort but this
is what it takes to get to releaseable
and getting read to a releasable state
in under an hour ideally
this were real engineering though
it would improve the quality efficiency
and the quality of our work and the data
says it does both
the data says that if you can get this
kind of picture at the kinds of speeds
that I'm talking about
the people that are working on it will
have more fun there'll be less burnouts
they'll enjoy their jobs more they'll be
more committed to the organizations that
they work for
the development approach will be more
scalable within the context of these
things and we'll talk about the reasons
for that in Us in just a sec but also
the businesses that we are working in
and we'll make more money users will be
more happy the software will be more
stable I use a tagline for my business
which is better software faster and
that's not a idle promise that's what
the data says if you read the Dora
report the state of devops reports the
door the writings about Dora at Google
and the accelerate book this backs this
up with some evidence that says that
this is a better way of working
when we're talking about release ability
strictly if I'm being very pedantic
deployability is really what I mean
because what I want to be able to do is
I want to do a small drip of changes
that may not yet add up to a whole
feature and but I'm going to end up
releasing those into into production and
this is a tool that we can use to to
define the scope of evaluation because
I'm going to evaluate my change to the
point of its release ability that means
I must be really
evaluating a releasable unit of software
if at the conclusion of my deployment
pipeline I now say oh I've got to go and
test that with these other services over
here before I'm happy to release it it's
not a deployment pipeline
what this means is
um if we're going from commit to
releasable outcome in this way then
that's the scope of Version Control
that's the scope of the deployment
pipeline that's the scope of release and
so we've got a concrete reason what what
you know how to apply that scope what
what that scope means in the context of
continuous delivery it means that
there's no more testing to be done at
the end of the pipeline Transit no
sign-offs no integration tests with
other components of the system
there are two ways in which we can scale
this
we can either grow the pipeline
and invest in the engineering that's
necessary to get answers quickly enough
from it
or
we can decompose our system into a
collection of independently Deployable
pieces Each of which we're comfortable
to deploy without testing alongside the
other pieces
that's the real definition of micro
Services it's not what most people that
practice micro Services think micro
services are very often but that's what
is in the definition
microservices is an organization
organizational scalability play it's the
most scalable way of building software
but it does this as a cost
this is a more difficult way of doing
things because now we've got to be able
to design pieces of a system that talk
to each other but that we can release
wholly independently of one another in
order to gain the benefits of
microservices and the scalability
oops
it's a new presentation and I've got two
versions of the slide sorry about that
so in software though
scaling is more complicated than it
seems and one of the ways in which it's
more complicated is
um
it's really this we can scale the size
and complexity of the systems that we
create and what most people think is
that that means that we can scale the
size of our organizations to create
things more quickly and we've known for
a very long time that that's a really
really slippery slope as we've just seen
with micro Services it's possible but it
comes at a cost in terms of complexity
operational complexity development
complexity architectural complexity
foreign
to coin a phrase by the
recently deceased Fred Brooks a a a a a
a genius of our of our discipline you
can't make a baby in a month with nine
women there are some kinds of problems
that have a fixed period of time a fixed
amount of efforts you can't you can't
scale up by just throwing people it's a
problem and in software this is a this
is a very very fragile thing
I like this piece of metadata research
it's not deeply academic but they they
analyze the results of 4 000 different
software projects of all different kinds
and sizes they divided the projects up
into teams of five people and fewer and
of 20 people and more
and then they measured two things first
they measured how long it took each team
to get to a hundred thousand lines of
code
as you might guess
on average
the teams of 20 people beat the teams of
five people
but
on average it took all of the teams
about nine months to get to 100 000
lines of code and the teams are 20
people on average beat the teams of five
people on average by one week in nine
months so on average a people working in
a team of five are nearly but not quite
four times as productive as teams
working in a team of twenty
small teams matter small teams are
deeply important if we want to do good
work in terms of software and that's
about learning and about managing the
complexity and those sorts of things
the other measure that they did
incidentally was that they also looked
at
um
and the number of defects that were
created and the teams of 20 people and
more created five times as many defects
as the teams of five
this gets us into ideas of like
organization or scaling and this is a
this is an idea that I learned of from
my friend James Lewis of thoughtworks
who got really interested in a field
called non-linear Dynamics and
complexity Theory Theory and this this
comes from there so the traditional way
of scaling an organization is something
like that you build sort of a hierarchy
and you have you know bosses and you
have you know teams of other buses and
you have hierarchies and buses until you
get down to the bottom of people that do
the work
um now the interesting thing is that
there's some maths around this these
kinds of structures appear all over the
place
and the maths is about the scalability
of these kinds of structures these kinds
of informational structures is
interesting if you look at this for for
these sorts of
um directed graphs of of information
people resources whatever there's this
number that keeps cropping up
0.85
if you have
um a team
an organization company that's
structured like this and it doubles in
size it's productivity it's capacity
it's profitability will go up by 85
percent it won't double
there's a there's a loss each time it
scales the flip side is is if you've got
a team like this then
um
if you if you double in size
you only have to pay 85 percent in terms
of infrastructure costs to get to to
keep it going
and this kind of crops up all of the
time double the head count Revenue
increases by 85 percent
there's another way of organizing things
though if you've got this and this is
this kind of loosely coupled sort of
social network
um
linked graph kind of approach
um this is the micro Services team
approach this is the dividing the
problem up into a series of small
independent teams who make progress
um independently of one another these
are more autonomous these this the
number here is 1.15
this is what Amazon does and the scary
thing about this is that when Amazon
doubles in headcount they more than
double in profitability
that's
explains
their explosive growth and and this was
a conscious Choice interestingly Jeff
Bezos is one of the the funders of the
Santa Fe Institute of non-linear and
non-linear Dynamics research that's
going on there
so he knew about this when he kind of
came up with the idea of this famous
idea of two Pizza teams and how that
scales better now there's a cost to this
there's a problem with this because what
you do is that you trade off
um consistency uh coordination
for scale scalability
you want these teams to be more
independent you want them to be in
control of their own choices their own
destiny in order for this to work if you
want to be able to tell them what to do
and apply more constraints to them
it breaks this model and you end up more
like this model and your scalability
Factor changes
it's a choice you can do either one
but there's more limits on this one
but some advantages and there are fewer
limits on this one and some are
disadvantages
so that's kind of the picture on the
right is is Amazon and the picture on
the left is kind of nearly everybody
else
um
so to scale up
problem solving needs to be distributed
that's how we get to scale up
to scale up what we need then are strong
motivated autonomous teams we need teams
to take responsibility this is borne out
in the research done by the state of
devops people the their data says one of
the strongest predictors of high scores
instability which measures the quality
of the work that we produce and
throughput the rate at which we can
produce work of that quality
the highest predictor is the team's
ability to make its own decisions it can
make progress without coordinating its
work or asking permission from anybody
outside of the team
so those are very different kind of
teams to what often we see in
organizations
so what does this look like in an
organization how do we think about or
managing such teams and and this is this
is taken from somebody else's work too
so this is from Gregor hope and this is
his advice of the way of thinking about
leading autonomous teams so the
autonomous team is responsible for
nearly all of their work they're near
they're responsible for making progress
independently of other teams so first
we've got to find a way of carving up
the problem in a way that we can give
them that autonomy and then we've got to
leave them to it we've got to let them
do the work experience the problem and
they're in the work so they're going to
be best placed to see any problems with
that way of working and improve those
things
but to do that
we've got to give them some Direction so
leadership in this context is not about
telling people what to do it's rather
about
defining the Strategic events it's about
defining the boundaries within which
their autonomy can autonomy can can
exist and that they can make progress
but we also probably need to support
those there's a I think one of the most
important books of the the last few
years is the team topologies book and in
the teen topologies book they you talk
about using team structure as a tool to
better organize software development
um and they talk about four different
types of teams
um
the core are is what are called stream
aligned teams those are the teams that
are building the software that people
want want that they're solving problems
for our users that the users care about
and then you have platform teams
enabling teams and complex subsystem
teams who support those and the idea of
these other forms of teams is to reduce
the cognitive load within the stream
aligned teams so that the stream align
teams can can stay focused on the stuff
that really matters the outcomes that
we're that we're shooting for
so the idea is that we
you define tactics common tools common
patterns those sorts of things to
support the work of the stream aligned
teams and allow them to make progress
independently of one another
so the first part is really about
setting the goal leadership is about
sort of planting a flag on a hill and
say wouldn't let's let's wouldn't it be
great if we could go over here imagine
how wonderful it would be if we could do
these things that's it
it's not about how they get there
the job of the team is to figure out how
they get there
so the job of the team is to do the work
and all of the work to make to to make
something that is genuine releasable and
then the idea of everybody else is to
support their ability to do that work
and to maximize their ability to move
quickly and and and deliver changes that
users outcomes that users really want
there are some techniques that we can
use to try and breed this sort of
autonomy in teams I would say that this
is this autonomy it doesn't really
matter whether you're talking about the
distributed graph kind of thing or the
hierarchy kind of model this is still
the best model for software development
this is going to optimize us to allow us
to solve hard problems within teams
without relying on coordination if you
go back to what I said earlier on this
is a way of reducing the coupling
between teams
aiming for these autonomous teams and
allowing them more Independence and they
can move at their own pace rather than
being held back by other groups of
people
so some of the techniques for breeding
this kind of autonomy are
um
goal or Mission based planning what I've
just said really what wouldn't it be
great if we could do this fundamentally
focusing on the outcomes rather than the
techniques that we use to get there
it's called Mission based planning
because this is a lesson that the
military learned a long time ago for
teams senior officers don't say go down
this road turn left through that gate
climb up that road and then shoot those
people they say take that Hill
sorry about the war like reference but
but mission-based planning is kind of a
way of maximizing the effectiveness of
people you want the people to understand
the problem
and then figure out their own solutions
to that problem
so the other part of this is to Define
simple well understood constraints we
like people on these teams to understand
what the goals are understand what the
guidelines are for the organization
understand what where they can
compromise where they can't understand
what is what are the parameters for
their their autonomy you can't just go
to a bunch of people that are used to
working in a more traditional setting
and say you're all autonomous now
because they'll sit there and they go
yeah really I know you don't really mean
that
if I'm autonomous I'm going to increase
my salary to three million pounds
it doesn't work like that so you've got
to say what the boundaries are you've
got to help people understand and allow
them to genuinely be autonomous but
within some constraints so setting some
guidelines is a good idea the other key
part here is what I mentioned earlier to
manage the cognitive load of the team
allow them to be able to make progress
on the things that matter to their users
and take away work you know develop
supporting technology practices
processes whatever it is that help that
team make progress but don't get in
their way
the job of a platform is not to come up
with some beautiful Ivory Tower solution
that nobody understands it's to service
those teams it's a service function
teams understand that need to understand
the problem that they're working on one
of the things I work as a consultant and
I usually work in larger organizations
and one of the things that I see all of
the time the anti-pattern that I see all
of the time is something that I call
programming by remote control using the
requirements process to tell people what
to do the Communist form of this is
having a UI team that Define what
exactly what the UI leads and that's
given as a requirement to be handed into
the development team
defining the UI is part of the
development
somebody might come up with a better
idea than a bunch of people doing that
and somebody might find out that there's
that that idea doesn't work very well
and need to change it putting that
responsibility into the autonomous team
is part of this and to do that the teams
need to understand the goals and so on
but deeply understand
um the problem that they're working on
and they need to own the problem that
they're working on
again the previous speaker was talking
about
um teams that were interested in going
out and discovering
um the pro the details of the problem
talking to real users and so on this is
something that we tend to have lost
sight of a little even within agile
teams but understanding the problem and
the ownership of the problem is a core
of being able to do a good job it seems
to me
I just want to give you a simple example
really this is in terms of architecture
because I'm a technical nerd and that's
why I kind of think think about things
but one of the ways in which you can
kind of constrain things is with
architecture and one of the ways that I
think of Architecture is not as a
prescriptive thing that tells you
exactly what your answers must be but
more like a tourist map
so you want an architecture that kind of
gives you a rough guideline of where
stuff goes and and the context of where
the thing that you're working on is and
how it sits
I use the these sorts of things this is
these are these are things that I call
whiteboard models and they're called
whiteboard models where they're kind of
a consensus of the architecture for for
a team and any at least any senior
member of the team is able to draw this
from memory on a whiteboard that puts a
limit to how complicated and how
detailed it can be because you should be
able to do this even for a big system
but it's enough for you not the reason I
called it a tourist map is it's like if
you go to the zoo and you want to know
where the gorillas are you can kind of
Follow that you know follow the the path
even though it's not geographically
accurate these kinds of these kind of
maps allow us to have conversations
about how software works together
without worrying too much about detail
these are useful tools that allow us to
move forwards
growing the responsibility and ownership
in the team
the best tool for this is Ensemble
programming mob programming or pair
programming I'm an old school extreme
programmer I'm I'm a Believer in pair
programming mob program is fantastic too
though I have had an opportunity to try
it but the idea is is that we get to
learn from one another it's the best
tool to help us lever up the quality the
culture in a team and the ownership and
the sense of responsibility for the
things that we're working on and the
understanding
and actually pair nearly everything not
just pair programming we want people to
be creative and to do that people are
that they're most creative when they're
working together on things talking about
things learning from one another all of
the time
so we don't need to formalize that kind
of training other than trying to
encourage people to work together
I would argue that the primary role of
leadership
um is to teach not to command
the goal is to help people
do the best that they can with their
skills their understanding their talents
maybe plant the flag that I was talking
about before but it's not to say You
must write this code like this you this
is your software this is the solution
that you must abide by
we scale decision making by making it
pervasive distributed and continuous
if you've got to go and ask permission
from some someone three layers up in the
management hierarchy in your
organization to do something that
doesn't scale very well that person is a
bottleneck your feedback your feedback
loop is too long
and we scale implementation by
optimizing for fast feedback on
releasability if we can do both of these
things that gives us an opportunity and
if you look at the organizations that we
think of as being good at this kind of
thing able to operate at Big scale they
do both of these things
thank you very much that's the end of my
tour